that ladies and gentlemen was a dramatic
flyover in Britain this morning to mark
a hero's birthday to world war ii
fighter planes flew over the home of
British veteran tom moore who turns 100
years old today now the world knows
captain Tom from his record-breaking
charity walk in his garden we all
watched that that raised tens of
millions of dollars to fight the corona
virus yesterday he was made an honorary
colonel that's higher than a captain
Charlie d'Agata is in Moore's hometown
of Bedford Charlie d'Agata I cannot get
enough of Captain Tom good morning
neither can we Gail you want a reason to
celebrate together this inspiration
we'll just take a look at this 125,000
birthday cards for Captain Tom who by
the way still wants to be known as
captain Tom another truckload arrived
this morning a lot of these birthday
cards are written by children this one
reads you're never too old to dream a
new tree what kind of guy gets a
Spitfire in hurricane flyby for his
birthday
a birthday card from the Queen I speak
for them and a message from the Prime
Minister we wish you a very happy 100th
birthday a guy like captain Tom Moore
can I be one of the first to wish you a
happy hundredth birthday you see you get
125,000 birthday cards this year how
many did you get last year remember a
lots changed since captain Tom
unwittingly stepped onto the world stage
a few weeks ago raised a bit of money
and support for overwhelmed health care
workers dealing with the horrors of
coronavirus we could all use a hero in
captain Tom's daughter Hannah believes
her father stepped up at just the right
time the message of hope and it's the
message that we are all united and it is
the message that it doesn't take one
generation with all in it together along
the way the now 100 year old World War
two veteran on a mission had found new
friends in high places he'd hoped to
raise maybe $1,200 it has soared to more
than 30 million last time I checked 36
million dollars in your wildest dreams
had you thought about raising that kind
of money and even when he'd finished his
walk his journey wasn't over he took
part in a charity single you'll never
walk alone and became the oldest British
number one artist in history
it would be nice if it was the youngest
what did you think when you heard the
news he brought a smile to my face
because oh dear look at all the
beautiful people who've been pushed up
the top slow beautiful people like The
Weeknd who urged his fans to get captain
Tom to number one over his own blinding
lights about the only thing that makes
captain Tom happier then all the love he
has received is giving it all back
[Music]
now Captain Tom's days of walking for
charity have ended but we do have an
update now listen to this it's now
around 40 million dollars that he's
raised 1 million dollars today alone
gala
I know Charlie yesterday we were talking
about Captain Tom in our morning meeting
about how we're gonna cover the birthday
today and we were told you were gonna be
standing there and I think Peter Burgess
said it best one of our producers said
this is a story with no downside
everybody we know is cheering for
Captain Tom how do you think how does
his family say he's handling all of this
Fame and all this acclaim and the more
he talks the more you fall in love with
this guy yes and when I spoke to him I
fell in love with him again and as I
said to both of them I feel as if I know
you and of course I do
and the whole nation has been rallying
around him in fact the whole world has
been rallying around him of course he's
going to be spending his birthday
relatively subdued with his family in
isolation and one day when we're all out
of this mess he'll have a proper
celebration and I can only imagine what
that's going to look like yes I know
Charlie d'Agata thank you god I hope he
has a piece of cake or two today hey
Tony to cope I love the cards and said
you're never too old or dream another
dream may we all make it to a hundred as
long as we can be in that kind of health
that's great no I agree completely I
mean a hundred is a very big number but
I keep thinking that even bigger number
36 million and now up to 40 million well
done captain Tom